county leaders are moving forward with
plans they hope will make the strip
safer a new ordinance aims to keep
anyone convicted of a crime within the
corridor out madison kimbrough is live
on the strip tonight after hearing more
about how it's going to work
we all know crime in vegas can really
happen anywhere but the county is taking
steps to ensure that it doesn't happen
here on the strip and locals agree as
they all they want is just to feel safe
again
it's been very scary
for as a local because
we don't know what's going to happen
next that was local chris baserto he
says he and his friends who work on the
strip have seen it change for the worse
in recent years and feels like something
needs to be done that's where the county
is stepping in an idea that has been in
the works for a while the order out
corridor amendment was unanimously
passed tuesday stating that if a person
is convicted of committing any crime
within the designated corridor they can
be banned from the area for up to a year
if a person has been convicted of a
crime there and returns to the corridor
and happens to be
subject to
arrest again for something
or let's say the police officer who
arrested him recognizes that would
subject that person to arrest for
violating the order which has to be
issued by a judge this new ruling used
to specifically be for trespassing and
prostitution but now applies to anyone
convicted of any crime on the strip
felony or a misdemeanor councilman
gibson also stating that this new ruling
will not be enacted right away but
should be in the next couple of months
it is not going to be enforceable until
a few other things have been done and
metro of course will have to be trained
in what all this means right so they'll
have to know the corridor and we're
hopeful and expecting that this will
give us results
and it should be known that this new
ordinance won't apply to the pedestrian
bridges for now for a full list of the
corridor map the designated one that
gibson was talking about you can head to
our website at 8newsnow.com reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now